Trascrizione: Beatrice Vecchiato
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Musica
Applausi
Buon pomeriggio!
Molto bene, thank you.
Perché Montebelluna Sportstystem?
E perché dei Megatrends
suggeriti per il mercato?
Io ho lavorato nello sport
per quarant’anni
Trentadue li ho passati
qui a Montebelluna.
Ho progettato prodotti
di articoli sportivi,
per piccole aziende, per medie aziende,
per grandi gruppi.
Ho diretto dipartimenti
di ricerca e sviluppo.
E Montebelluna è nel cuore.
Per cui in questa occasione
di essere qui per TED
non potevo che parlare di Montebelluna
e del suo Sportsystem.
Perché suggerire dei Megatrends?
Perché bisogna avere la capacità,
a livello di sistema,
di guardare molto avanti.
Cosa sono i Megatrends?
Sono dei trend, delle tendenze
socioeconomiche consolidate.
Io ne ho scelti cinque.
Potrei dire che ce ne sono
una ventina a livello mondiale.
Bene, ne ho scelti cinque.
Vediamo quali sono.
Economia circolare.
Ridurre, riusare, recover.
Bene, l’economia circolare ci dice
che tutti gli sprechi che noi procuriamo
nelle nostre attività
possono essere reimpiegati
e possono creare valore.
Diversamente cosa facciamo?
Li buttiamo sotto terra,
facciamo un gran buco
e li mettiamo sotto terra,
oppure, spacchiamo tutto e diamo fuoco.
No, ci sono strade ben precise
in questa direzione.
Noi abbiamo due tipi di rifiuti:
i rifiuti biologici;
i rifiuti biologici sostanzialmente
sono stati affrontati da anni
in maniera puntuale,
e quindi noi possiamo
disperdere nella biosfera
acqua pulita, aria pulita,
elementi di fertilizzazione
del terreno puliti.
Gli altri rifiuti, che sono quelli tecnici
hanno bisogno di una cura
molto particolare.
Per cui ecco che allora,
noi possiamo pensare anzitutto
di ridurre l’impiego dei materiali.
E qui si apre una grande opportunità
per i progettisti:
bisogna progettare
con la mentalità dell’eco-design.
Ma soprattutto, per esperienza,
bisogna progettare
con la logica del disassemblaggio.
Guardate quanti oggetti
che ci sono qui attorno:
provate a disassemblare questo televisore,
ma di sicuro costerà di più
che averlo costruito,
di sicuro sarà difficile
separare i vari componenti.
Quindi, parlare delle tre “R”
vuol dire all’inizio pensare
al ciclo di vita del prodotto,
vuol dire pensare alla culla
che fa nascere questo prodotto,
al suo degrado,
e alla prossima culla
che farà nascere altri prodotti.
Questo è il messaggio,
questa può essere una bandiera futura
per il sistema dello Sportstystem:
le cinque scelte che ho fatto
sono dedicate allo Sportstystem.
Secondo Megatrend:
Silver Society.
Eh sì.
Il primo dato è l’aumento
della popolazione mondiale.
7.6, 2050 è domani per l’economia, 2050.
9.9 miliardi di persone.
La previsione è
che il 20 per cento di queste persone,
di questi umani,
sarà over 65, più anziani di 65 anni.
Io ne ho 74, sette-quattro
quindi sono, mi rendo
perfettamente conto, in quell’area.
voi dovete pensare
che attualmente in Giappone
più del 26 per cento
della popolazione è over 65.
In Italia siamo vicini al 22 per cento,
siamo il secondo Paese.
E questo trend continuerà. Perché?
Ma perché l’aspettativa
di vita è aumentata.
In questo momento per i maschietti
è 80 anni e qualcosa,
per le femminucce 85.
Ma continuerà ad aumentare!
Ma soprattutto, ci sarà un saldo
demografico negativo,
soprattutto nei Paesi sviluppati:
le donne fanno meno bambini.
Ma quale sarà il problema
di questi sessantacinquenni?
Over sessantacinquenni.
Mah, di sicuro molti di loro
hanno problemi di respirazione,
di sicuro hanno problemi
di mobilità articolare,
sia nelle gambe, sia nelle mani.
Come possiamo noi allora aiutare?
Possiamo fargli fare delle
attività motorie di gruppo.
Perché di gruppo?
Perché l’altra grande
situazione di disagio
di una persona anziana è di sentirsi sola.
Questa società li ha buttati da parte,
in maniera più o meno conscia.
Non c’è più la casa
del contadino di una volta
dove il nonno, la nonna,
gli zii, erano tutti,
e quindi c’era questo trasferimento
di cultura e di esperienza.
Non è più così: è una società,
come si dice, atomizzata.
E quindi facciamogli fare
delle attività motorie:
nuotare, camminare, non proprio
correre, correre, correre,
andare in bicicletta, ballare,
e diamogli dei prodotti che siano facili.
Che sia facile da chiudere la giacca,
che siano facili da indossare,
che siano facili da portare,
perché questo è quello che chiederanno,
e il distretto dello Sportsystem
è preparatissimo a prendere
questo grande mercato.
È un mercato di un miliardo di persone:
non è una nicchia, è un mercato!
È un’opportunità di business.
2.1 nel 2050?
È un mercato.
Terzo trend.
Saranno veramente smart
queste urbanizzazioni?
Mah, di sicuro stiamo vedendo che
il dato che più mi ha
impressionato è questo:
nel 2050 il 72 per cento
della popolazione mondiale vivrà in città.
No, città, in megalopoli!
Non metropoli da un milione
di abitanti: megalopoli!
30 milioni di abitanti e più
per Tokyo, Delhi, Città del Messico.
È come se noi prendessimo l’Italia,
che ha 60 milioni di abitanti,
la raggruppassimo
in due grandi contenitori,
e la distribuissimo:
30 milioni da una parte
e 30milioni da un’altra.
Voi vedete che la Cina, l’India…
beh, arriveremo nei Paesi sviluppati
addirittura all’86 per cento
di urbanizzazione.
Ma cosa potremmo fare in queste città?
Mah, di sicuro ci sono delle
proposte intelligenti:
il bosco verticale di Boeri
a Milano è un esempio.
Parigi 2050 è un altro esempio.
Le città che diventano le metropoli
che cominciano a interagire
con l’environment,
cioè con quello che gli sta attorno,
e producono profitti.
Ma potremmo fare sport in queste città?
Ricerche di università inglesi
hanno chiaramente dimostrato
che chi corre lungo una strada trafficata,
e voi li vedete,
annulla completamente
i benefici di quell’esercizio fisico.
E non correte in fianco
alle macchine che corrono!
Ma in questa metropoli,
o in queste metropoli:
Pechino nel 2050 JJJ
130 milioni di abitanti,
100 mila chilometri quadri coinvolti,
collegati però in maniera velocissima.
Treni che corrono non più
a 300 chilometri all'ora,
a 600 chilometri all'ora.
Quindi, uscirà il concetto non più
di città, di metropoli, di megalopoli,
ma il concetto di rete,
e muoversi all’interno di questa rete
in maniera efficiente, efficace,
permetterà di accedere
a delle zone verdi, a delle zone…
Questo è il futuro.
Non so come l’Italia riuscirà a creare
questa rete, ma questo è il futuro.
Cosa potrà fare lo Sportsystem?
Di sicuro chi si deve muovere
avrà bisogno di oggetti leggeri,
di oggetti che siano
facilmente igienizzabili,
e soprattutto avrà bisogno,
in una città smart dove
l’Internet of things,
cioè l’internet delle cose,
le cose che parlano tra di loro
e che parlano con te,
dove l’Intelligenza artificiale
sarà dominante,
avranno bisogno di avere la
Wearable Technology,
la tecnologia indossabile,
che è esplosa in una maniera incredibile.
Nel recente Expo
io ho partecipato a un convegno
di un membro della mia piattaforma,
l’EPSI, piattaforma europea dello sport,
e ho visto 800 progetti mondiali
presentati di tecnologie indossabili.
Ormai si può sapere tutto di voi
e con dei costi molto bassi.
Next.
Mobility.
Questo è un altro trend.
Questa slide mostra il movimento aereo
attualmente in corso.
Nel 2016 hanno viaggiato in aereo
un miliardo e 300 mila persone
e voi vedete che c’è
uno scambio incredibile, fisico.
Perché fisico?
Ma perché le compagnie low cost
hanno dato questa grande opportunità.
E se aggiungiamo questa mobilità fisica
alla mobilità dei dati,
noi possiamo in tempo reale
sapere cosa succede in questo momento
a New York o a Pechino.
Noi possiamo fare una conference call
seduti in macchina
dall’altro capo del mondo.
Bene, questa mobilità fisica
però deve tenere conto
dei diversi segmenti del mercato:
i Millennials si muovono con logiche
diverse degli over 65.
Le persone anziane cercano nella
mobilità turistica sensazioni
e feedback completamente
diversi dai giovani.
E se io voglio legare le attività
dello Sportsystem
a questo Megatrend?
Ma di sicuro avrò
un problema di salti termici.
Io viaggio molto verso la Cina
e quelle zone,
e parto qui d’inverno a zero gradi
e arrivo a più 30 gradi!
Però mi è successo anche il contrario,
che a un certo momento
ha nevicato in un posto così.
Ero andato via con i bermuda,
tutto bello leggerino,
e invece si è messo a nevicare.
E quando uscii dal taxi e feci
[annusa l'aria] così col naso,
perché noi sentiamo
l’odore della neve, lo sapete,
e dissi: “Qui nevica!”
e questi si misero a ridere:
“Ma no! Qui non ha mai nevicato!”
Dopo un quarto d’ora: neve!
Eravamo a Taipei.
Ok, io ero con i calzoncini corti,
e quindi sono dovuto correre
a prendermi qualcosa.
Allora, se avessi avuto,
invece, un’attrezzatura,
scarpe, abbigliamento e tutto quanto,
che era aggiustabile,
se mi potessi coprire come una cipolla,
la raccomandazione che ti danno
quando vai in Inghilterra
o quando sei di fronte
all’Oceano Atlantico:
copriti, scopriti, perché in questo
momento piove, e dopo viene il sole…
e questo è un altro tema.
Chi viaggia ha dei problemi lo stesso,
vuole oggetti leggeri, facili,
facilmente igienizzabili,
e vuole essere collegato col mondo.
Obesità.
La slide che vedete,
non quella a sinistra che vi dice
che non potete più mangiare
il gelato alla fragola
perché è quello che vi fa
diventare obesi, ok?
Non è così.
Ma questi sono
i miei studenti all’università
che fanno queste presentazioni
e io li lascio fare,
perché se li facessi io
da vecchiaccio di 74 anni
probabilmente farei delle cose
molto seriose e pallose.
Questi sono i miei ragazzi.
I dati che vedete sono del 2012.
Non è vero che in questo momento
ci sono 500 mila obesi,
ce ne sono già 600 mila.
Non è vero che ci sono sovrappeso
1 miliardo e 500 mila persone,
c’è un miliardo e 900 mila persone.
Io sono obeso?
No, sovrappeso.
Usiamo un parametro che si chiama BMI
che ti dice quando tu metti il tuo peso
e lo dividi per il quadrato della tua età,
ne esce un numero.
Sotto il 25 sei normo peso,
dovrei pesare 74 chili e ne peso 81.
Tra 25 e 30 sei sovrappeso,
oltre il 30 sei obeso.
Bene. Cosa possiamo fare per questi?
Di solito gli obesi hanno dei
problemi notevoli.
Il primo problema è
quello delle sofferenze
che il sistema cuore-polmone porta,
per portare avanti queste masse.
Gli possiamo far fare delle
attività motorie?
Certo che sì.
Anche queste saranno
delle attività motorie non invasive.
Dovremmo soprattutto
proteggere gli arti inferiori:
tendenzialmente l’obesità
porta ad avere le ginocchia,
le gambe ad X,
e ad avere addirittura
una pronazione del piede all’esterno,
quindi, ci dovrà essere
una grande cura in questa direzione.
E ancora una volta lo Sportsystem
è in grado di rispondere
in pieno a questa situazione.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
Applausi